a continuación noticias destacadas de la
pandemia aquí en france 24
llegaron a perú las primeras 300 mil
vacunas contra el cob y 19 del
laboratorio scinopharm el presidente
francisco sagasti aseguró que en muy
poco tiempo comenzarán a ser
distribuidas a las personas que luchan
en primera línea contra la pandemia
el gobierno de sudáfrica suspende el uso
de la vacuna contra el coi 19
astrazéneca en su programa de vacunación
después de que estudios mostraran que
dio una protección mínima contra la
variante originada en ese país las
autoridades de salud informarán sobre
qué hacer con dicha vacuna
con pruebas de coronavirus negativas en
la mano los viajeros partieron de
beijing china para pasar vacaciones del
año nuevo lunar en sus lugares de origen
con un número notablemente menor a los
viajeros que en años anteriores aún se
podían ver multitudes